[Musica]
[Applauso]
fioriranno le stelle le code
luminose di comete silenziose
le scie
di Boing supersonici che tagliano
recise il cielo
siamo Il sogno di Morfeo la
scomposizione della luce in prismi e
colori
siamo creatori costruttori disegnatori
di sogni di notti stellate di notti
sbandate di note sbagliate
di scie
di stelle cadenti che poi
non cadono
[Musica]
capitolo 1 futuro
chi siamo da dove veniamo
Dove andiamo
la curiosità l'esplorazione e l'ingegno
ci condurranno nuove scoperte in ogni
campo della conoscenza della non
conoscenza della
trascendenza sempre
mantenendo
intatta la distanza
con il mistero della vita
[Musica]
capitolo 2
contaminazioni positive
ci siamo
sfiorati qualche volta
intercettati incrociati distratti tra
gli urti di spalle nei pensieri densi
della metropolitana di
scontri fortuiti di carrelli della spesa
di incroci stradali non rispettati
di coincidenze mercati e di treni per
di miscugli di miscele di emulsioni di
contaminazioni positive
siamo
Un incredibile mosaico con 8 miliardi di
tessere ed infinite combinazione
[Musica]
capitolo 3 ambiente
il nostro pianeta
[Musica]
brilleranno piogge mentre
ben tre splenderà al sole
vividi arcobaleni
sorgeranno sulle carcasse squartate
delle petroliere accasciate nell'oceano
Pacifico
al di sotto degli Scavi
l'esplosione di colori degli
affascinanti labirinti delle barriere
coralline Le melodie dei canti dei
Boscimani della Namibia la voce
cinguettante del merlo sul ramo
dall'orie in giardino
il profumo di gelsomino e caramello
della torta di riso della cucina di
Nonna
le insegne luminescenti dei centri
commerciali lasceranno il posto ai
lampioni accecati da qualche sasso e
alle lucciole
[Musica]
capitolo 4 linguaggio
ci verrà richiesto di essere
flessibilmente precari
Camaleonti mutevoli naufraghi di tempi
Incerti reduci dalle crisi dei destini
generali e poi poi ci sarà un punto in
cui non si capirà più nulla non si
capirà più nulla in cui dovremo
riprogettare gli spazi integrare i
luoghi e riscrivere il linguaggio
per renderlo maggiormente capiente ed
inclusivo
l'intelligenza artificiale ci aiuterà a
creare nuove forme di comunicazione
immediata e maggiormente contenitive
[Musica]
capitolo 5 Guerra e pace
mentre
l'intelligenza emotiva
produrrà un inversione nel campo
magnetico un cambiamento climatico
i
neh
B Le
una siccità di proiettili
dove le guerre
seccheranno
senza l'acqua dell'avidità e
diventeranno
polveri dei deserti
[Musica]
capitolo 6 tecnologia
creeremo perfino perfetti modelli
algoritmici
un'applicazione per
sospendere lo scorrere del tempo perduto
per rivivere i ricordi felici
per imparare dagli errori per cogliere
perfino l'essenza della solitudine
poi
ci fermeremo
disorientati di fronte a una strada
sterrata con i nostri dispositivi GPS
fuori uso immobili
ci guarderemo
ci annuseremo
ci ascolteremo
ci toccheremo
ci gusteremo
capitolo 7 amore
[Musica]
siamo le rovine
dell'Impero Romano d'Occidente
siamo capitelli decapitati del Partenone
siamo specchi spezzati piatti tirati
pianti velati
siamo i cimiteri di guerra i Prandelli
di Campi Minati ancora in esplosi pronti
ad essere disinnescati
deporremo le armi toccheremo i nostri
tatuaggi di Piero classi e lapilli
sommersi dai Ruscelli colorati della
nostra doccia di baci scivolosi di un
bagnoschiuma dal ph neutro
per spogliarci delle nostre quotidiane
scorie radioattive
impareremo ad amarci come quella volta
che da grandi Sì da grandi siamo andati
oltre il cimitero degli elefanti
dei militarizzando i nostri confini nel
prestarci
il battito del cuore
[Musica]
forse
da qualche parte
di questo multiverso ci vedranno Come
delle stelle luminose
immortali eterne che bruciano glucosio
inesauribile e non combustibili fossili
siamo la meraviglia dei colori
dove il mondo si trasforma in un grande
caleidoscopio di emozioni di rifrazioni
di Riflessi di riflessioni di riflettori
su un palco di luci stroboscopiche
specchiate sull'oceano
ci lasceremo sorprendere dagli
imprevisti della vita
sentendoci sempre almeno un po'
inadeguati
e
fuori posto
poi sempre
lentamente
proseguiremo il nostro viaggio
evaporando
nella meraviglia
dell'arcobaleno
[Musica]
Grazie Ted Grazie Forte dei Marmi
[Applauso]